and thank you Yankee for being here
today with us for our global growth
event and for doing this interview with
us
so Yankee is the co-founder and CEO of
oho can you describe what oho is for our
audience absolutely
so our first well I got new thanks very
much for having us I'm very excited to
be here to share our story so an awful
is the first smart on station free bike
sharing program in the world so what we
do is that we provide the station for
bikes and for people to use to unlock
with their smartphones it's very easy
accessible it's it's very green it's a
very smart way of getting around the
city especially for the last mile great
can you talk about the scale as well
like how many cities are you in how many
trips do you cover yeah absolutely so as
of today we are in 180 cities and we're
doing over 25 million trips a day and we
have deployed over 10 million bikes
already and we're in right now globally
13 countries the goal here is that by
the end of this year we're going to go
to at least 20 countries that's
phenomenal I mean it's a truly unique
for a Chinese company to really go
international this fast before I touched
into how you did the international
expansion I wanted to hear your story on
your one you know what was the
motivation to launch Otho and how did
you guys go about doing that basically
the company was founded by a group of
passionate cyclists so it was found at a
university when we were in university so
the very natural thing is that you have
your bike in the university but I think
probably like this something everybody
has experience is that a bike been
stolen and or like a lot in San
Francisco actually unfortunately yeah so
found himself like he lost 4 bikes
during his during his university period
of time so yeah so we come up with this
idea of what if like we have shared bike
system like people don't don't need to
worry about like biking stolen be be
like like like like when you go out of
station right there they're still like
1.5 miles to go but you don't have any
transportation methods you have to walk
or something like that on what if we can
solve that problem right so that's
that's where so like the idea
came about I think this kind of last
mile commuting problem is with you of
that in China but right now we know
alike it's actually a universal lake so
it's everywhere right there is not a
before us there's there's not a like
very good solution for that right so so
yeah so that's that's that's that's
where we where we came from and and it
was very natural like like any other
startup in the world like we we came up
from like one wanting to solve a very
simple pain point of people's regular
daily life right so uh so yeah so we
started in 2014 and in university right
and boot University legging University
okay yeah so basically that's where
you're the founding team studied so
basically like we start from there and
we spend some time to expand to 200
universities at the beginning and
starting from 2060 end of 2006 end of
2016 we expanded to the cities so in the
city markets because we have the
experience of running operations and and
and all the systems like like like
within the university so in the city
it's different in our but there's a lot
of things we can borrow it's always
scale really quickly we spend eight
months to expand to over 170 and 80
cities LA and in China also include some
international cities right now mainly in
China and the trips grew from the
beginning was 200,000 trips last year
right now is over 25 million so there's
there's a big growth there yeah yeah so
so that's that's what like our story and
our trajectory yeah so I'm so I wanted
to go back a little bit on the first
year when you're launched in the
university how did you launch did you
make your own bikes because you
obviously wanted to move from doctor
stations to something that people could
access anywhere so how did you what was
the supply in the first year yeah so
it's interesting because at the
beginning the idea was to use like we
called a hundred percent sharing model
it's like we use the existing bike to
sort of like as a supply source so in
China we well in China is called the
king of bicycles we have a lot of
bicycles so when we start the business
we look at the statistics the annual
sales of bike in an existing stock a
bike actually in China we have
400 million bikes so it's very natural
thoughts like what if we activate that
existing supply rights just like uber
darn Diddy is like huge amount out there
so on so that's what we did at the
beginning so basically what we do is
that we go out there and telling people
through different channels like we're
doing this shared bike program and
everybody's welcome to donate their bike
to our system we started something like
we call exchange one for n which means
like you donate your bike and and then
you have access to all the awful bikes
in the system right so we think that we
thought that does this people would love
it and then like a lot of my bike will
be donated but what actually happened is
that it's a very new idea first of all
and second is that like not actually
many people are willing to like give up
their like personal positions like like
then my share right then beginning it's
hard for people to to quite understand
the idea so at beginning the supply
growth is actually quite slow like every
day I think we collect 30 40 bikes then
that's that's that's a number on at the
same time like the demand actually grew
very fast like well we wouldn't put the
first batch of bike on the street on the
street on university people just loved
it explosive like people like talk about
it different like forums everything like
people love it the only thing is that
people complains they cannot find the
bikes the people like they saw people
students writing bikes but they cannot
get one for them because there's not
enough bikes nice so that was the moment
really
we started think this super growth is
very bottleneck for us so how do we
solve this I so I think back in 2015 we
came up with this idea of going to the
largest manufacturers in in in China
which isn't hinging as a city very close
to Beijing that's where most of the
largest bike manufacturers are and in
China in the world so we go talk to them
we basically we start this to expand an
idea of sharing bike sharing right so
it's not just about sharing the existing
stocks but also but also about like
bringing the new bikes that the
manufacturers tend to sell plan to sell
to the individual buyers to our platform
to be shared by people right so on
average our bikes of 20 times more
efficient than the private bike on our
platform on average one bike serve
over 20 users like like compared to like
every bike serve one people right so um
so yeah so we came up with with this
idea and then we approached them and
then we started to have a small trial at
the beginning because we do not have
much funding in the beginning so we buy
some bikes and then we put in the
university and and well also like well
you have your own suppliers it's very
easy to control the qualities and also
like the the colors and then the bike
itself right so we have a hundred
percent control of your supply and and
that's when we call the small yellow
bike was born right so we have that back
then that's like it's like we have the
bikes and we pin the bike but it's like
it's it's not the summery good so so
when we have our own supplies I painted
the existing banks yeah so back the to
air source think there's two abandoned
bikes sometimes we don't paint we just
like it use the bike and at our lock so
you when you walk in university you see
our lock that means that's awful bike so
it's not very easy to identify sometimes
and also I cuz they're different bike
types does not look very identical so
yeah so basically like the the new model
works better so that's that's the
solution we find to scale or supply and
it works out pretty well and very
quickly we expand to like 10
universities 50 universities and we
spent a year to to expand to 200 mercies
which is quite a lot yeah in China
hundreds Emeka share profitable and
people love it
students love it and so yeah so that's
that's that's how our story begins mhm
so you expanded to 200 universities by
the end of first year yeah the end of it
so basically we started Wow like
graduate pick it up and and we started
in 2015 of this like new model of
purchasing the bikes and expand and we
spent a year from 2015 to 2016 and we
focusing on expand to different
universities because universities like
it's a closed area in China most of
universities have like the walls so it's
it's sort of like a sort of like a
natural closed area where like like you
don't need to worry about like if I
could be taken out of the university
because we hire people our stuff like at
the gate like people cannot go out right
just like a baka so it's very easy
and also like it's it's much more much
simpler environment in terms of the user
behavior mm-hmm like on students is like
like they were the where they live where
they go where the library's refectory is
like the the jeans the football fields
its dorms like it's very very easy to
sort of like do the rebalancing it's
very simple I would say the the scenario
so I think that one year actually give
us a lot of insights like a practice
about how to organize the operation even
that back then we do not have a very
smart system we use like Excel sheets we
use like sometimes just write down
different universities but that gave us
like a very good experience on how to
manage a ground team right so like like
how many people we need for how many
bikes and how to maintain the bikes and
what bikes we need right because people
like they will see like Reichman broken
and and like like how do how do we do
Batman rebalancing right so what how
much time your advance would do we need
I mean what scenarios so so actually we
have a lot of experience and being play
booked into into that into that into our
operation model in that year which where
we can borrow yeah for the for the seed
expansion so I think that's one of the
most important important reason why we
can spend so fast skill so fast in the
city because when you figure something
out in a smaller scale I think so like a
natural like like a close this
involvement yeah sort of like like I
like it like like a trajectory it's like
we figure something out in a small
environment and then you gradually take
it out and also in at the beginning we
do see the expansion and we do not just
go to like a lot of cities we go like to
districts in Beijing or Shanghai and
like we try to solve like I have a
managed managed expansion and have some
experiment ok this is how it feels like
in the city and how people have how
people use it this is this is like how
should we do like a rebalancing because
in university is very easy like we use
certain type of vehicles to do the
shifting and balancing stuff and
everybody in a city difference it has
different regulations so for example in
Beijing we can use this three will
electric vehicle to sort of like to move
bikes which is very efficient but in
this lot of southern cities in China
like ginger and Guangzhou of the cities
these vehicles are banned so you we have
to find different vehicles sort of like
sometimes we need to modify some of
the small vans to to to do the
rebalancing so so yeah all this kind of
like challenges specifically in the city
we need to tackle it's an interesting
observation here it's even though you're
very different from a social network I
think Facebook often talks about that
like the learnings for them was the fact
that they did a university and
university or a lot at first they'd
figured out Harvard then Stanford and
then you know before they opened it up
to the MA you know to basically to
everyone they had 80% penetration in
universities in the US and they talk
about how they figure out how to build
the product such that there was high
engagement in universities so it's a
very interesting parallel and so I'm
going to ask you when you were in 200
universities how did you decide when to
switch to the city and what motivated
you to switch to the city and how did
you think about you know because as you
said for all the elements why the
university is so different from city how
did you tackle that first city that he
went to yeah I think there have been
discussions of going to the city very
early probably like from day one I think
there are a lot of we think there are a
lot of conditions of going to the city
right so we need a lot more bikes I mean
in then in the University and the bike
itself need to be upgraded because in
the university we use simple bikes
regular bikes in the city proper we need
to use bikes with gears bikes with like
much more like a lot of like anti-theft
features being implemented which will
increase the cost everything so um so
yeah so basically we spend a lot of time
first of all researching developing the
bikes that we need for the city do test
them in very small area so so yeah so
basically like we developed it by for
the city and we expand operationally to
the to the University so that's what we
do in the first year and at the certain
point we think that first of all we're
ready on the product side and also like
we're ready on the operation on the
operation side one third is also on the
market right so we think that in China I
think there are 2000 universities and
but the best ones are like the top 10%
so we're in quite we have a quite good
coverage of the of the of the of the
good quality university is like which
has the best I would say the the campus
structured construction and also like
the university students quality and
everything so
um so yeah so basically feel like you
like in us you you you have all the Ivy
League or the UC system right so we have
all that on we think that okay so the
next search probably like we can we can
go to the city and also like in terms of
like the team right at the beginning the
company was created by founded by like a
student project but later like we
upgrade the team up obtainment and
certain so important like we have we
have like the CD management CD operation
management team set up we think that's
that's the time because we when we go to
the city want to make sure that that is
a win and we have we have there so this
is a sort of like a band we take so we
didn't make sure we have the necessary
resources necessary necessary the
necessary team and product ready before
we go to the city so so that was the
moment I think last year I think
November October November was the moment
like we think okay this we're ready
right we start expecting it was a talk
about the playbook for each city so when
you're desiring to launch in a new city
what do you what's the first step is it
hiding a city GM is that putting up a
weightless like what is it yeah so on
how do we how do we launch cities both
domestically internationally is that
first of all we would do will do a
research will do on like a city list
digging where you do like which cities
are the target cities alright so we look
at a lot of metrics like I think there
are over like 20 of them like including
the population density like the penny
the credit card penetration the
smartphone ownership how the city's plan
and also like the the price for the
public transportation for taxi how much
money how much does your money the
household average spend on every month
on transportation and stuff all this
like metrics etc etc like would come up
there's a formula so we come up with a
city list on Marcus sighs Ryan also like
what's the history of the local 30s like
about like the new technologies new
companies and I call these right away
would quantify it and then we have like
a list of cities out there in China
internationally
right so so we find the cities so that's
sort of like we called Air Force
approach like you need look at it yeah
and then we could we look at we look at
the marine approaches and with send
people we would send people on the
ground
right sort of like the launchers or
basically the launchers right sometimes
we send operation managers ala launchers
but some people on it how many people do
you send in China actually we because
we're already in 200 or sities to start
with so we have teams in 200 not to
understate it's about like I think 50
cities I so like like we have like very
good resources like we just have some
people like to go to the city do some
fashion and stuff so it's easier to
start but for international markets we
do we need to hire launchers and and
send them so but the hiring process
start like a few months before we the
the launch date of their national
business so today how are the people
like most of them like Chinese at the
beginning they have experience of Lamy
international market international
countries or like doing business there
and stuff so we send the first batch
launchers landing team on the ground is
it like 5 or 10 people something like
that yes I think it's like 10 plus 10 so
that's a different like one people to
one country somewhere and then they go
there and they launched the the do the
basic setups right and well first of all
they need to do what they need to do is
that actually the market research the
greenlight process so they go there
spend like are we could or we can to
actually elect to to cross-check with
what the Air Force is found has found
right so all those metrics what's real
really like and how people think about
and everything and talk to people
actually try out the local public
transportation and feel about experience
and everything so yeah so the greenlight
process will take one week or so one or
two weeks and then we have the have them
start to start to to establish the the
basic foundations of the company right
so a we will start to initiate the
contact with the local 30s we start to
like the recruiting process because well
like I said we need a local team to run
around around the business like in the
long term so they're starting to recruit
the local people what's the team
composition initially for a local t like
what are you looking for is a GM with
few support like what's the structure
yeah so the ideal structure would be
like a GM City GM and and with operation
because we're like quite heavy on
operation so maybe one or two operations
one in terms of like managing the
mitaina staff one is men imagine Pike
right so it's like cycle operation and
also like on the marketing side we also
need people do the use
acquisition the the PR like the things
but in terms of like hiring orders so
it's the it's the city GM and the
operation team and the marketing team
but sometimes like fine to find the city
GM's its lower prices that very fast so
we would probably start with the the
operation teams like so so yeah every
city is different so most of the city
are wrong by launcher so launchers
everybody restaurant is doing everything
so it's like that and that's very
similar to to most of the most of the
expansion model by other Internet
companies I don't say only one
difference is that we are operation
heavy so basically like we're put put
more I would say their attention on the
operation side so that's that's that's
how we do so so yeah so basically that's
the basic structure it's also we can you
talk a little bit about the operations
because it's a little different from
ride-sharing right right sharing you
have someone who's driving their own car
and you're requesting where the app and
it take helps to take point A to point B
at offer you have your supply of bikes
so and people can drop it anywhere and
pick it up anywhere so can you talk
about what is the operations entail yeah
so the operations is there is a
different different de categories all
right so is the most important ones are
the bike deployment the bike route
balancing vitamin tennis all right so
these are the key things so at the
beginning obviously like we have the
bike in the city and we basically we
should buy from China or some factories
in Europe and in different parts of the
world so we have the bike it's the when
the bike enter the city it's the
operation team's own responsibility to
uh to to maximize efficiency of the bike
so basically a deployment right so where
to put the bike to begin with right for
example like in what in small cities
it's easier right so it's just like put
in a city transportation hub yeah but
for big cities like London like like
maybe like wow like like like like San
Francisco I can well we're not in
services good yet but if we if we do
probably like oh we started with one
district right instead of like going to
the whole city so so yeah so basically
like we will find like the most bike
from either the most bike-friendly or
the like the most dense city in terms of
population there
some Criterion's you can use to find
those locations and then you start a
deployed bikes and also there's another
criterions that other thing you can look
at is like where are the areas in the
city where people open our apps most
frequently you play before wearing the
see press it we see that heat map is the
okay this area actually maybe it's a
student area like a lot of like a
Chinese students wear a so they're used
I'm sorry you found out about Singapore
right yes so in Singapore is that we see
that heat map we said okay when we when
we try to decide which is the first
international city to go we see like the
the global map where like we have the
most usage most user activity before
wearing the city all right so we see
Singapore's obviously is the most
popular one and we go there and yeah so
so the business business took off very
quickly yeah so so that's that and there
must be some some areas in the city like
has that fat factor but that's only one
thing to consider right so there are
different things and also like in some
places like we we talk to the government
and there's some areas like it's the
local authorities need us to provide
assistance for example in in in Austria
like we have very good relationship with
local authorities like we started with
district 2 and and the second district
we go is that district 221 which is I
would say NASA T is kind of like far
away from the center and it's less like
mobility options for the for the for the
citizens and if we go there it's
actually add up to the add up to the add
up to the mobility like people to have
have can have their so so yeah so this
type of things are all in our into our
considerations so basically our
principle is that I would go to the city
we want to help to see solve their
mobility problems we want to listen to
the city what they need and and we
provide our solution so that's that's
that's our way to to work with the C's
so so yeah so so I think whenever we go
we make sure like we have that
conversation we be transparent we're
transparent with the with the local
people and local authorities on what we
what we are and and what we can do to to
make sure like it's a it's a win-win
situation
yeah and you're present in the US now
right yes so we launched the Seattle
okay and and I think we launched two
cities in East Coast in the in the
Greater Boston area as well and more
cities the condo
great so what do you think you know many
people are skeptical about the us right
from bike sharing and I know you've
often told me that even in China you
changed the behavior of the people to
use bike sharing so what's your view of
the US do you think that there is enough
demand for the bikes and do you think
they'll be a behavioral change so I
think the weekend to like take one step
back and ask the question of what a city
needs right no matter it's a Chinese
city US city like what she needs what
are people leaving the city need right
so I think to get around the city right
get on the city you know smarter greener
on like more affordable and and like
more accessible way I think it's it's
always better right so if there's
something like like you can use like
like match all this criterions above who
must use it so that's our basic basic
assumption so if that assumption stands
I would say like they're actually not
quite big difference between city to
city in the world in terms like what
city needs all right so that's that's
that's where we where we start to think
so secondly obviously like there are
different characteristics of different
cities some cities are like more dense
some cities are more sort of like I'd
say the hilly than the others yeah some
cities are more like the transportation
public transportation development stage
is different people like different
cities people are willing to spend
different money on transportation for
example in Brazil on like people the
average household spending on the
transportations 30 percent of their
income so this is super re but a maybe
in u.s. is much lower
yeah and also like what is people what
people's like like like habit like like
like existing behavior for example in
Paris the the the the percentage of
transportation by bike is only like
single-digit like three or five percent
but a Hamsterdam is 30% is many times
higher so so yeah so every city is
different right so other thing is that
first of all the last mile commuting
problem is universal number two is that
I think for most of the cities people
need I think like well most of these
people don't have
like very convenient like like a smarter
in a cheap way of getting around last
mile so so that's why we are and where
we kick in so so I think us cities also
have that have the absolutely problems
or like characteristics obviously I
think in in San Francisco in Los Angeles
in New York because like the seas are
very different on but I think we're very
confident like our solutions will be
something like people have never
experienced before so and and and we are
here to solve the problems probably we
need make some product upgrades like our
adjustments probably we need to make
some make some operation adjustments but
I in terms of like making adjustment to
adapt to local markets I wouldn't say
like a US market is very different from
let's say Japan or France or UK right so
we make adjustment all the time yeah
that's what we do
got it great yeah a few and a few
adjustments are obviously needed to
cater to the local market so let's talk
about an electric bikes because I know
you've briefly mentioned that so what's
the vision for Ophir going forward yeah
so if you look at the trip distance
right now first of all like in the city
right so it's actually most of most of
distance are short that's a short trips
in the city and you can see like what we
do as bike sharing company regular bike
mechanic bike right so what we do is
that normally the the trip distance
ranges from 300 meters to three
kilometers that's where that's where
like the bike of people the distance
bike can can help so and that is like
for every city that's that's good right
so obviously I think the natural next
step is that we want to extend our both
ends yeah well on the short ends like we
see that happening already people are
getting lazier I so it's like before
that people are willing to walk through
Mithra meters but right now with bikes
even like water meter I right sorry
and on the probably we don't need too
much things on there just improving the
writing spirits on the far end probably
like there are a lot of things to do
right so with mechanic bikes we are
constantly improving our writing
experience right now we see a very
steady like like like like a growth of
the trip a distance like from circa
mares right now is close to 14 meters
less
like people tend to write more about
write longer when it's easier to ride on
but I think with the electric bike that
that a far end of the distance can be
extended significantly probably to three
millimeters to like ten commuters so
that can actually cover most of the
trips that are done in the city so
basically just imagine like in the city
people ride electric bikes um and and
there will be a lot less cars in the
city right there the pollutions the
congestion the the accidents like all
these things will be much better for the
environment reduced yeah you'll see like
people like the city is getting better
yeah the people are also like in terms
of price right you can take cars and
citizens expensive right so or owning a
car is expensive so so yeah so like if
you think about how people get from
point A to point B in the city on
regardless of what like like like if
vehicles we use I always think about
like what is the most economic way
Safeway Greenway right easy way to to
get around to complete that distance
right so we are we trying to find like a
like a more advanced vehicles to to to
satisfy that demand so I think you bike
is very natural option of that and also
like I saw like there's there companies
care like a school like like similar
things to do that
so yeah so we're we're very optimistic
and it would actually we have ebikes
in China been tested in different cities
and we see very promising results on
that obviously like there are different
economic metrics there are different
like models right so how to change the
batteries how to store like charge the
batteries and how to do the operations
will be different but I think ebikes
is is one of the one of the things we
are we're gonna sort of like put efforts
on in the future got it yeah great and
how big is the team right now
so in try to have 2,000 plus employees
it's a big team and for international we
have a bit more than a 100 so it's still
very start very early stage yeah and
yeah so I think the principle of the
company in terms hiring people is that
while obviously like like we're very
lean team
hire the best of the best and we also
like love to have people on board who
share same passion with us right so like
we want to we want to really make
changes of the world of the city like on
how people get around mm-hmm and
providing more options more choices on
to the to the to the people so so yeah
so that's that's that's awesome how do
you think of the of your product when
you know self-driving cars are pretty
much dominant everywhere in the world
today there's obviously more challenges
they need to solve to go to level fire
nation with computer vision problems and
you know solving the last mile but in a
world where you have you know pretty
much self-driving cars how do you see
you know Oh for bike sharing or electric
bikes playing a role yeah yeah first of
all like I love to see that day you have
to love to experience that like like
like so yeah so first of all like I
think even if like people have choices
like autonomous driving cars like
everywhere still there there will be a
very huge demand in terms of the battery
I'm not sure whether we're gonna rule
out it like self-driving bikes but even
if you consider like the current product
all right so I think there are a lot of
advantages here number one I would say
is is the density right so you look at
you like look at how the city's plan may
like maybe in San Francisco like this
the car can go to almost everywhere
because the city is like blocks and
everything but in many cities like in
South Asia in developing countries like
in China there are a lot of like small
roads cart cannot get in obviously their
arguments like you can probably like put
the put their travelers car you win take
the driver out of the car you can change
the change the shape of a car like like
it looks like a Batman's like a
motorbike something like that you can't
you can do that right so so so yeah but
within that being said with that being
said it's still like I think density is
something like like the the shared bike
has has advantage on number two is cost
so basically like Thomas driving car is
a beautiful product about my thinking
sad - manufacturing that to put in the
scale is going to require a lot of
investment and to operating that system
and to use that system is going to be
very costly so so it's like it's like
you think about it right so especially
at the beginning of that he still need
to a lot needle object to maintain the
system right like in the same time like
I would say how much what is the pricing
of taking a timeless driving car like
like like I don't know what pricing but
I my imagination just feels like a fancy
service and could be like could be kind
of well the cost of making car is
significant but the driver cost in the
right sharing should go away ideally
yeah so basically basically like like
for for the for the for the bike itself
right now like we do not have a driver
we do not have do not have a cost of
energy we don't have electricity's right
those all like main power so it's like
cost wise we're going to be much lower
in terms of so can you compare the cost
per trip today on an hour versus a diddy
um yeah so I mean well it is non self
driving yet yeah so it's not just based
on today because that's an interesting
observation yeah so I think there is a
there's a few like a interesting feel
like main categories so number one is
the is the is the driver opportunity
cost so basically for a ratcheting model
you need to pay the driver like the wind
when he gets online there's there's
always like charging prices like you
need pay for him like hourly rate or
whatever rate like like like a you need
to there's a cost there and that is a
variable cost so basically like you'd do
one more trip there's always like a
drivers take on that right so that's
number one number two is on the the
energy cost is basically right now most
of the cars are running on gasoline
right maybe some electricity but still
like most of them are on a gasoline so
there's a huge cost there also that one
is variable cost so on so like forever
trip more distance you travel like the
more you pay for the gasoline and for
the driver right so so these calls
aren't gonna go away but for bikes like
like we we most of the costs we have is
a fixed cost so basically the cost does
not go up as we scale as we as we do
more trips so at the beginning when we
have less users like the bike or maybe
the bike user twice a day right so so
that's that's that's that's that's
that's how we how the structure is but
later when we have more users in the
biker use like five times in university
was wrong sometimes go up to ten times
so
when that comes the cost does not go up
when we when we are when we do the
increase the increase the number of
trips so still like a way we pay the
same amount of salaries to the to the
maintenance workers and with our smart
system like actually their working load
does not increase likely still like like
the well when they manage like 200 bikes
they maintain like they spend time to
repair maybe 30 bikes a day and we would
have when we have them like manage 1,000
bikes our day what we do is that still
like maybe repair thirty five bags a day
so it's still like that doesn't go bad
the efficiency the cost operation cost a
per bike has actually goes down hot
because you get more leverage yeah I'm
you know 20 you said like you get 20
rights a bike right in some university
we can we can get to 20 and our record
is over a hundred times a day
so that does that is that is well that
is when I saw it once so so bye-bye
normally it's like 10 around University
so so yeah so it's quite it's quite it's
quite a different model so so for us
it's more like a rental model all right
for registering it's more like a writing
model I say yeah and and well if you
think about like a ton of driving
obviously you take the driver out yeah
right so there is no cost for the driver
that's a massive increase of the
efficiency but still like I said like I
said like the there's a there's a
maintenance cost of the car I think that
would be possibly be higher than Amma
tenants cost for a bike mm-hmm all right
so and also like there is there's
density issues yeah and there's also
like the system management Rises so it's
like I don't know too much about the
autonomous driving but my guess is that
the the total cost of operation and
management will be will not be cheaper
to and maybe higher than what it takes
to a bike yeah maybe I don't know like
maybe the whole the total cost me has
been higher than the current system yeah
horses yeah only time will tell
that's we'll see see yeah but I'm pretty
a big fan of Thomas driving so got it
yeah well thank you so much Yankee thank
you so much for taking the time to speak
with us thanks for having me
yeah okay
you